дорога ще в кийки на тему перехрести
піт попасне точиться ваше бої
врятував рига чого без я регулярно виявляти
сюди фіксую воду порушення мінських ось ти
воронку очевидно знесення покину українські
солдати брутають нас із собою на передову і
дражнив перебуваючи в лисиці білля попасну я
чистий і тисну commander щасливі ще до
сильним авт рад за рідними і простягається
нейтрально смуга
так звана сиро зона демілітаризованої
район 1 кус очистиш звивисті відкриває
вогонь по українським в яках фронту в
музика до гарячої води за 200 метрів
видно з постріл і гранатом ці
вакула мотиву сепаратисти кожен вінду
потрібно перемир'я
мені все одно на агресію на здавлювати
дають балію викликати моєму в чому він і
youtube
a b c твердити втомлюємося годиною українці
теж дали частину тихіше чому пару фото
режим пропаяні його вогню бийте з
простого та колагену base pack для життя
здоров'я наших ризиків і службу
розуміється команди відкривається побачити
повірити розтушовується вас останнього
за долі до сміттєзвалища мінському і думав з
37 порушення режиму 1000 зафіксував
цього дня українська вся кава з постере
goccia боячись йенаро хвали 300 ви бухи в
за два дні
витрачаючи заступника зі стрільби у вигляді пізно діяна
мирного рішення